>> Judge Jeanine: WELCOME
BACK TO THIS SPECIAL EDITION
OF HANNITY.
NOW, ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE
NEWS OUTLETS TONIGHT, A
HIGHLY ANTICIPATED REPORT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
EXPECTED TO CRITICIZE FORMER
FBI DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW
MCCABE FOR AUTHORIZING
IMPROPER MEDIA LEAKS ABOUT
AN INVESTIGATION INTO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION BACK IN
OCTOBER OF 2016.
THIS SAME IG REPORT IS ALSO
EXPECTED TO GET INTO THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
THIS NEWS COMES ON THE SAME
WEEK THAT MORE THAN A DOZEN
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS IN THE
HOUSE SENT A LETTER TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS URGING HIM TO
APPOINT A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE BOTH
THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE'S HAPPENED LING
OF THE TRUMP-RUSSIA PROBE.
CALLING FOR A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
HE JOINING US NOW.
ALL RIGHT, GOOD EVENING,
CONGRESSMAN.
>> GOOD EVENING, JUDGE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NOW, YOU ARE RENEWING AS ARE
MANY REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
THE REQUEST FOR A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
NOW, I IMAGINE THAT MOST
VIEWERS ARE SAYING THEY DID
IT BEFORE.
WHY SHOULD IT HAPPEN NOW AND
WHAT'S NEW THAT THEY ARE
ASKING FOR IT AGAIN?
>> JUDGE, THE LAST TIME WE
SPOKE ABOUT THE ABILITY FOR
DEMOCRATS TO CONVERT
POLITICAL CASH INTO A
GOVERNMENT SPAWN SOARED
WARRANT TO SPY ON MEMBERS OF
THE TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM,
YOU SAID YOU WANTED TO SEE
PEOPLE LED AWAY IN
HANDCUFFS.
NOT JUST FIRED BUT LED AWAY
IN HANDCUFFS.
FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AREN'T GOING TO BE
PUTTING THE HANDCUFFS ON
THEMSELVES.
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL AS
CONGRESSMAN LEE ZELDIN HAS
RECOMMENDED SO WE CAN TAKE
THE FINDINGS OF THE IG
REPORT.
TAKE THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
LEARNED IN CONGRESSIONAL
HEARINGS AND ACTUALLY HAVE
PROSECUTIONS BECAUSE MY FEAR
IS THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL THIS
WILL TURN OUT A LOT LIKE THE
BENGHAZI INVESTIGATION WHERE
WE LEARN A LOT ABOUT FACTS
BUT NO ONE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT BOTHERS ME,
CONGRESSMAN, IS THAT GIVEN
THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, DILATORY
APPROACH, YOU KNOW, TO
EVERYTHING, FROM THE HANGING
OVER OF EMAILS FROM THE
REDACTIONS, FROM THE
OUTRIGHT REFUSAL BY EVEN THE
FBI DIRECTOR SAYING WELL WE
WILL WORK OUT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE CONGRESS WHICH
HALLS OVERSIGHT OVER
JUSTIFIABLE AND THE FBIS,
YOU KNOW, IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THEY -- IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE, THEY BASICALLY
HAVE SAID EVERYTHING BUT WE
DARE YOU BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO ANYTHING ANYWAY.
WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, CONGRESS DOESN'T
HAVE THE POWER TO THROW
PEOPLE IN JAIL BUT WE HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO FIND
THE EVIDENCE AND SHOW IT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND TO YOUR POINT, JUDGE
JEANINE, IF WE HAD NOT HAD
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT AND
HEARINGS AND SUBPOENAS, WE
WOULDN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT THE
TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN PETE
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE THAT
DEMONSTRATE A SUBSTANTIAL
ANTI-TRUMP PRO-HILLARY BIAS.
YOU MENTIONED ANDREW MCCABE
EARLIER, HIS TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IN CLOSED SESSION
SHOWED ME HILLARY CLINTON
WAS NEVER REALLY PUT IN
JEOPARDY AS A RESULT OF HER
USE OF A PRIVATE EMAIL
SERVER AFTERNOON THE LEAKING
OF CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
BECAUSE SHE HAD PEOPLE THAT
WERE RUNNING INTERFERENCE
FOR HER AT THE DOJ.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO PEOPLE WHO SAY I
AM SO SICK AND TIRED OF THIS
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION
THING.
LET IT GO.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> WE CANNOT LIVE IN A
COUNTRY WHERE LOSING AN
ELECTION FUNCTIONS AS DE
FACTO IMMUNITY DEAL.
IF PEOPLE BROKE THE LAW,
THEY HAVE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
IF WE JUST ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN, THEN WE INVITE THAT
TYPE OF CRIME IN THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHY THE RULE OF LAW
MATTERS AND THOUGHT CLINTONS
THEY HAVE DECADES OF
IGNORING THE RULE OF LAW AND
NEVER BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO CHANGE
AND IT WE NEED TO TAKE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT ARE
THE CHANCES OF GETTING A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSELOR.
>> THAT IS UP TO JEFF
SESSIONS.
>> IS HE A GUY WHO TOOK
HIMSELF OFF WITHIN 24, 48
HOURS OF BEING APPOINTED THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE TELLS THE PRESIDENT I'M
RECUSING MYSELF.
I MEAN, THIS IS BEYOND THE
PALE.
JEFF SESSIONS IS NOT GOING
TO DO IT.
JEFF SESSIONS SAYS I'M
GETTING AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
WE CAN SPEND ANOTHER YEAR
AND A HALF ON INSPECT ARE
GENERAL COMING UP WITH A
COLLUSION.
WHAT IS THIS GUY DOING.
>> WELL, IF JEFF SESSIONS
DOES NOT APPOINT A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL, THEN WE
NEED NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL,
JUDGE, BECAUSE YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
EVEN IF WE LEARN MORE
HORRIFYING THINGS FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, WE CAN'T
ACTUALLY PROSECUTE SOMEBODY
FOR THOSE THINGS BECAUSE WE
WOULD NEED SOMEBODY TO BE
ABLE TO BRING THAT CASE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND FINN OBVIOUSLY WON'T BE
BRINGING A CASE AGAINST
THEMSELVES.
SO JEFF SESSIONS NEEDS TO
GET RID OF THIS MIND SET
THAT DERELICTION OF DUTY AND
HE NEEDS TO DO WHAT CONGRESS
HAS CALLED FOR AND APPOINT A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSELOR TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF.
THIS JEFF SESSIONS, YOU
KNOW, SAID HE WAS
CONSIDERING THAT AND
CONSIDERING INVESTIGATING
CERTAIN CASES.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT WAS
THE EMAIL THING OR THE
FOUNDATION, WHATEVER IT WAS.
HE GAVE US ALL HOPE A FEW
MONTHS BACK.
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED FROM
THAT EITHER.
THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT HE IS GOING TO GET RID
OF SESSIONS, RIGHT?
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY
I'M SURE WILL HAVE A
CONNIPTION AND ALL HIS
SENATOR FRIENDS WILL SAY
IT'S A SATURDAY NIGHT
MASSACRE.
SO, I MEAN, DOES AMERICA
JUST KIND OF KEEP MOVING AS
THOUGH IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO
VIOLATES THE LAW?
>> I NEVER UNDER ESTIMATE
THE POWER OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
REMEMBER WHEN THERE WERE
SOME PEOPLE IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY WHO
DIDN'T EVEN WANT TO RELEASE
THE NUNES MEMO.
BUT BECAUSE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
CONTACTED THEIR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND DEMANDED
TRANSPARENCY, WE GOT IT
THAT'S WHY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEED TO BACK UP WHAT
LEE ZELDIN AND MANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
FIGHTING FOR TO GET A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL SO PEOPLE
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
THROWN ENIN JAIL FOR THE
CRIMES COMMITTED AGAINST THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AGAINST
THE TRANSITION.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU GUYS
NOW ARE REALLY PUSHING HARD
ON THIS.
DO YOU HAVE MEETINGS WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE
YOU SOUGHT DOWN WITH HIM
OVER A GLASS OF MILK, A
GLASS OF BORE BON, WHATEVER,
AND SAID COME ON, SOMEWHAT
PROBLEM HERE?
>> DID I SIT DOWN WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ALONG WITH
JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN BOB
GOODLATTE AND MANY OTHERS.
I WAS DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL DIDN'T SEEM
TO BE VERY ENGAGED ON ANY OF
THESE ISSUES REGARDING
EXISTENTIAL THREATS TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
HE WAS DEFERRING TO A TEAM
THAT ANSWERED TO ROD
ROSENSTEIN FOR GOODNESS
SAKES AND IT WAS
ROSENSTEIN'S VERY SIGNATURES
THAT REAUTHORIZED THESE
WIRETAPS BASED ON FALSE
INFORMATION THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
FBI KNEW WAS FALSE
INFORMATION.
I THINK WE NEED A MORE
ENGAGED ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> Judge Jeanine: WELL, WAS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THE
COMPANY OF ROD ROSENSTEIN AT
THAT POINT OR ROSENSTEIN'S
CHIEF OF STAFF?
AS I UNDERSTAND USUALLY IS?
>> IT WAS THE MEMBERS OF THE
ROSENSTEIN TEAM THAT WERE
PRESENT AND WHEN MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ASKED JEFF SESSIONS
TO BE MORE AUTOER ISIVE AND
TAKE ACTION ON SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL, HE DEFERRED
TO STAFF MEMBERS.